foreign
North is as remote as it is Extreme
it's not an easy place to reach an old
rickety sleeper train one of the only
ways in
wow
the air here is so Bleak and so bitter
it literally catches your breath
tourists and locals alike bracing it's
genuinely dangerous to stay outside too
long
Moher is known as China's North Pole
it's exposed extreme and exceptionally
cold temperatures this week sunk the
lowest in modern Chinese history it's
actually hard to describe the cold here
it's so intense it literally takes your
breath away and any moisture on you in
your eyelashes or your nose it just
completely freezes up and it's hardly
surprising really because we are about
as far north as you can possibly get in
China across this Frozen River those
Hills over there that's Russia
it's freezing air from neighboring
Siberia that's caused this and it's
excessive even for those with experience
Mr Shear was born here he lives and
works in this small shop he welcomed Us
in for hot water and respite
you're going
years
scientists have linked warming Seas to
cold snaps in places like this and it's
remarkable when contrasted to this China
saw a summer of historic heat waves and
droughts part of the Great Yangtze River
dried up
the cold here is used as a target for
tourists this traditional Festival made
entirely of ice hodie is traveled here
from hot southern Guangdong a victim of
The Summer's extremes uh
people here are increasingly conscious
of the global slide towards climate
catastrophe but even for a place no
stranger to severity it is a remarkable
new Record Helena Smith hey Long John
province in northern China